we wanted to cover this i just haven't
gotten to it but we got some good news
for you lily fans
lily's show we already mentioned is
coming back but don't worry
they're completely changing it and they
fired most people that worked on it
except for her
most of the guys the nbc late night
series is scheduled to return in january
lily singh is making some changes to her
nbc late night show for its second
season
on screen a little late with lilly singh
oh
wait a little way a little
[Music]
we'll have a new set uh ditching a
traditional desk and couch setup
a house oh no but that's to say the
house is a is for a house in los angeles
that will give lily
more room to move around and try new
things yes
so new so nbc's way of fixing
lily singh show was the same plan that
ice beside and baked the last guys just
stream
our house streamer house well here's the
thing mike i don't know if you know it a
lot of these companies just
own these homes already anyway so they
let people stay
so instead of having to pay for studio
space now they just you know can use a
home in la oh my god
and it's it really it's going to make
you look even more bush league it's
going to make you look even more like a
youtuber who got lucky
that sucks me remember carson daley you
still got to bars like in you know
interview people
and now you're going to get lily singing
in a house in los angeles
well somebody on twitter even reminded
me too like craig ferguson right like
he kind of sucked at first oh yeah but
he got good
he got good because he was like all
right look i just want to do a good late
night show
and i just want it to be funny and he
hired some funny people
and he followed the funny instinct he
didn't try to pander to anybody he
didn't go what are people looking for
craig ferguson knew look these people
just want me to be funny for an hour
so i gotta find a way and that's all he
did and he got really good at the job
after a while because you're like oh
craig ferguson's [ __ ] hilarious
he didn't go you know what we need is a
[ __ ] stream at our house
we need a house in l.a where we can have
a whole bunch of people
i need women writers the series also has
a new show runner and neil
pence allen oh good comedy central's do
she's from comedy central's doing
the most with phoebe robinson i have no
idea what that
is who steps in for elia silverstein
and a largely new writing staff a little
late is set to open in second season on
january 11th repeats of the season are
currently on
airing at the most very coveted 1 35 a.m
time slot
um during the first season of a little
late
i was thrust into a whole new world that
admittedly consisted of 90
learning and 10 percent being creative
said sing for the second round i know
the ropes
do you the balls on her to act like
i know my way around now this is easy
and plan to bring more of my creativity
to the table
it's time to get goofy being perfect and
bring my full authentic self to late
night wait so let me get this straight
with the problem
so the pro oh so late let me get this
straight
so the problem with the first season of
lily sings show
was that it was too perfect is that what
i'm getting is that what i'm
to believe yes the [ __ ] balls on this
[ __ ] you know i just we just felt like
the first season was like too
successful it was too perfect we need to
dial that back um they're going you know
what's going to happen when this season
does bad too right
they're going to start calling it a cult
following
you know they're going to start calling
a cult following like a cult success
or yeah yeah you're right uh
chelsea davidson davidson has been up to
head rider on a little late
oh good good uh she'll lead the staff
that also includes vanessa jackson
oh the vanessa jackson jamal
roman balancino namcy patel
nola honda and natasha van van blatt
other than davidson the staff is other
than davidson the staff is all new so
they fired all of the writers
they fired all of the writers which
shows you that they really had faith in
the show
and will be tasked with putting together
a show that blends sketch comedy
interviews and sings observations of
current events in pop culture
so basically a bunch of sketches were
singles
lily what are you doing in the house
lily hey lily
oh sure mike like she's going to do that
like she's going to do
something like that what are you talking
about
contractors just left and i moved my
last boxes in we're official
still can't believe we're engaged
speaking of the future considering get
it dude it's [ __ ] woke cause it's too
living together
and you can tell they're different women
because she's wearing different wigs
i thought it'd be a good chance to
review my emergency kit oh yeah i have
mine from my old place but two is better
than one you got band-aids right
just a bunch of dildos that would
actually be funny so she wouldn't do
that yeah no dildos would be funny that
would actually be an old
old-school kind of comedy bit like just
a bag full of dildos opens it up and
they all tumble out and you're like i'm
so sorry
it's so embarrassing the last thing we
need that death
yeah i have band-aids i have all the
necessities okay i have waterproof
matches flashlights straws
straws your purifying water duh you can
drink straight out of the toilet with
these
we have a pool but okay what else is in
there
i probably shouldn't drink pool water
either yeah i mean actually the pool
water would be worse for you than the
toilet water yeah do you do you do not
understand right that there's chemicals
yeah the chlorine
levels in pool water is not great for
you to be drinking
i mean you can have a you can get a
little bit of it in your system but you
can't be drinking it
whistle battery zip tie blanket wait
wait why would we need zip ties i don't
know just add things down
or together is she gonna be a murderer
so she's ripping off dennis from always
sunny i need my tools
i hate this woman like what i don't like
wires supplies wrists branches
what was that i also have a flare gun
box cutters various flotation devices
tweezers tweezers okay baby you're not
gonna care if you have a unibrow or an
emergency okay
rude they're not about my eyebrows okay
there's a take out foreign objects am i
the only one that wants first off
terrible trigger discipline
am i the only one that wants the [ __ ]
flare gun to go right off in her head
i want the flared gun to go off and
cause a flash fire
craig ferguson's out locks the door now
use canceling
the all-new craig ferguson show on cbs
1 35 a.m i'll start at the bottom again
you're like you know what man this guy's
fine
that's fine buddy what kind of foreign
objects
anything debris bullets splinters teeth
bullets wait teeth you think i played
operation religiously as a kid for fun
no i have a very steady hand
is she supposed to be a murderer like i
guess
that's a joke
usually these kids just have like staple
items speaking of which where's my
staple gun
come here buddy you're really preparing
for the worst huh you have to be that's
why i have a geiger counter a detailed
map of north america and the andes a
sword and
cyanide tablets is there any talent in
that bag
maybe comedy can we pull some comedy out
of that bag i mean i think you're being
a little
i'm asking for too much you're asking
for way too much right all right you're
right you're right
can i tablet okay we don't need that but
you know what if we need to
you think she does drugs
um i mean i would think anybody that's
in that world
probably does drugs at this point like i
can't imagine anybody being in woke
television
and not like you you have to you'd have
to dull your senses on some level
because these people can't like look i
know we goof on lily singing [ __ ] but
she didn't get this far in life being so
dumb that she doesn't at least a little
bit know somewhere in her soul
that the entire agenda and all the [ __ ]
she promotes is wrong
there's a little nugget inside of her
that knows that
she's not good at what she does most of
the people in her industry are lying to
her when they say she's good she knows
all this
somewhere in her heart so yeah they're
all on drugs everyone in this
industry has to be on drugs to deal with
it
but i don't think she's like all [ __ ]
up
just leave them in
i'm sorry i'm trying to get the phone
what happened in the forest
the helicopters looking you see if you
make like wacky hand motions it's funny
right
yeah if you're funny just like no no no
no no substance
just wacky hand motions i hate this
i would have i would rather have her
replace with carrot top
i'd rather have a repla
think about it i stopped myself out what
were you gonna say i'm so curious hold
on what were you gonna say
people visit okay so like on the
roadside i got you yeah
okay i hear you take that turn slower
i had to i had to stop that wasn't bad
no that would have
yeah you're right yeah you're right that
would have gotten us in trouble
you're right you're right
have you seen a stack of passports
social security numbers and birth
certificates
what oh never mind they're hiding under
a barrel of sulfuric acid hot typical
uh it can melt anything or anyone
wait lonnie is this a butcher's diagram
of a dog
oh my god don't worry silly
it's out of date okay um i think you and
i are preparing for two
very different types of emergency how so
well my kid has things like burn
ointment
gauze and band-aids okay well sounds
like your kid sucks butt what are you
planning for scrape me at the park yes
wait are they moms okay sorry i i'm in
the middle of this
almost at the end of this bit are they
supposed to be moms i thought they were
the lovers
i guess they're moms that are lim lovers
got it i don't know
are those band-aids even waterproof
they're spongebob let me show you why i
keep the desert camo in the emergency
panic room we have an emergency panic
room
oh how cute why do you think the
contractors were here earlier
babe are you okay my foot is wet big
press the button again there's no time
this will have to do
she's not funny
167 000 views the video was put up
yesterday
14 million subscribers 19 000 likes baby
she's hot
and only 220 221 down votes
only that many 221 yeah because i just
hit it
well i learned recently that uh youtube
does
also disappear dislikes for these
channels yeah
because you did it for they did it for
tim decker
do they really tim heidecker has that
show on showtime that's going to be
terrible that he somehow may
manage to make like even fred armisen
not funny that's how
bad it is but um yeah we uh
a bunch of people like we were all
disliking the [ __ ] or whatever
and then it uh like i was keeping track
of it and then the next day
went back and looked and they were all
like a lot of them were gone the
dislikes were gone and obviously
and people who disliked the video didn't
get their accounts all nuked
it was just they just went back and yeah
dude it's [ __ ] crazy
well because a lot of these channels
right they have they have deals with
youtube they paid good money for them so
youtube also helps them out by making
sure that they're
the show looks like it's gonna do good
yeah
hey you stopped did you know i'm doing
vlogmas on my second channel
that's right did you know that nbc told
me that if i don't start doing something
soon i'm
[ __ ] did you know an executive at nbc
said if you don't if you don't find a
way
to turn that youtube career into a
successful television show
you can take your [ __ ] ass back to
twitch or wherever you came from
and they literally said or wherever you
came from
i went to her vlog channel her vlog
channel was made
in 2011.
she has two million um views
and i mean i'm really sorry we have to
watch one i'm so sorry mike
please i'm sorry look you have coffee
now so you should be all right
um yeah i have coffee now so you might
not be all right
you're right please don't throw it in my
face look i didn't do this i just have
to
we have to watch this okay here's your
latest vlog
cheap and romantic d do-it-yourself
christmas gifts definitely no makeup huh
for bae good morning i feel like i was
in a car accident
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is this a new blog yeah and she's still
using the word bae
yeah like young people this came out in
the in the way
history of yesterday dude this is like
young people
aren't even saying bae anymore i'm not
being murdered by a circle with a
chainsaw it's actually my landscapers
slow down slow down
[ __ ] but she's slow down it's your
channel you can do this as slowly as you
want slow down but this is a female
trait women think if you talk really
fast
it's funny and it's exciting and that
something's going on
because there's nothing going on like
this is the type of video by the way
this is why i went and i've even said
this on night wave when people like
you know when it when i see like people
that put out videos of like
nothingness like irl people who do that
they'll
they'll they'll live stream themselves
eating mcdonald's and you're like
okay but there's nothing happening
thomas does that and it's awesome thomas
murphy does that and it's great
well chick-fil-a but does he he talks
though right of course you know he's
thomas that's great
what i'm saying is people always like
see these guys that put out all these
content all these creators to put out
content and it's like
this is the same kind of content the
reason i could never put it i don't care
if i was super famous i couldn't make
contact like this because
you're like oh you got to make videos
for the page and be like who gives a
[ __ ] that my landscapers are here right
now like who gives a
[ __ ] that i'm getting a christmas
present why would anyone care about that
i just operate under the assumption that
people don't care about vlogs
well i'm gonna do an unboxing video you
know yeah
yeah of what's gonna have brad pitt's
wife's head in it
it's gonna be great i'm gonna do an
unboxing video it's gonna be lily sings
nudes
i close that box
[Laughter]
exciting news lily
frosty frosty the snowman my landscapers
are here and they're putting in a
pomegranate tree if you don't know about
me pomegranate is my favorite fruit in
the entire world cosmic joe cause i
can't eat it on keto but they're
installing it is the point check it out
how much do you think that cost
a pomegranate tree of fully mature
fully grown pomegranate pomegranate tree
being installed in your yard
and now we're now we're also we're also
have to adjust for this is in la
she's just like you guys it's got to be
i'm looking yeah i'm going to say it's
got to be expensive though period
that's not a cheap item oh any kind of
fully matured
fruit-bearing tree that you're buying
and then having landscapers put in
he's [ __ ] expect that's not cheap
it's not like you planted a lemon tree
and you're like wow when i have kids
someday they'll have lemons back here
you know what i mean it's we're talking
about uh huh yes landscapers i'd like
you to bring a fully matured uh
pomegranate tree i like that she's
filming her landscapers too doing all
this work while she's inside just you
know being terrible
that's true like i didn't even think of
that but yeah filming these poor guys
somebody's saying it's 25k i don't know
if it's that much
but yeah when i first moved here i was
like i don't need a landscaper why does
anyone need a landscape that's so bougie
and then i used to make fun of everyone
that had a landscaper you have a
landscape slow
down she thinks this is look i'm telling
you man women think that
fast and loud is funny and good
they think like women that aren't i'll
put it this way women that aren't
confident
are like
things
like that's just they think that they're
really heavily trying to mask the fact
that they have no personality
and they're afraid that if there's just
a moment of silence that you're gonna
see
into their soul and realize that they're
a useless [ __ ] hole
that's just my thought anyway she sounds
the way a panic attack feels
yes no you know what i mean yeah when
you're just racing somebody's
racing hey remember you said you were
going to mail the light bill
just just for a second please
stop like if you get a panic attack you
just go
please please everyone stop paper who
it was stupid and i realized because in
california landscaping is so important
because if you have dead trees or dead
bushes it's a fire hazard
no fire and also like you know because
we have so many illegal mexicans here
that we have to keep them employed
somehow well someone's got to do it
california so my toronto self was just
like what are you talking about but it's
a real thing so it's important so i take
the else
you want to go so these vlogs that she's
doing but she still jump cuts them
of course at the party do you promise
not to attack the landscapers
get enough for me let's go mom don't
watch me
i don't know why i just showed you my
dog peeing felt essential all right time
for some morning stretches if you don't
want to hear the sound of my body crack
intensely stop watching right now oh no
don't worry lily if there's one thing
i'd love to hear
if there is one noise i would like to
drift to sleep to
every night it's the sound of your body
cracking
except it's along the side of a
a cliff in hawaii or over bane's knee
yes yes
you think the executives are your ally
by the way it sucks that like everyone
knows the batman broke his back lore
before that movie came out
because it ruined that movie because he
knew it was happening literally every
super fan
sat in that movie and went he's gonna
break his back
he's gonna break his back watch bro
if you find that satisfying keep
watching to start
did you hear that did you hear that a
few ankle twists
so i have been trying to stretch every
morning look at the poster behind her
it says lily singh sees the night
it's her show lily singh
sees the night was that a special or
something she tried to do
that's what i think that was i are you
sure you sure was just wasn't like a
poster for her show
there's no way she did a stand-up
special how could she
why not nicole arbour did and that
woman's completely vapid
ponzi does make a huge huge difference
obviously yesterday at five in the
morning i did not stretch
and now i'm feeling the pain of that
i've also just come to the conclusion
that i sleep stupid i think i sleep in
stupid positions that's cause you're
stupid
by the way imdb
what's wrong mike is it a good rating
a little late with lily saying how's it
doing out of 10 stars what do you think
what would i give it or what do i think
what do you think not what you would
give it
because i hate this plan well i'm going
to let you cheat i usually this is like
one of those
exams where you actually help the
student
it's imdb not like rotten tomatoes and
not like
oh four see because because yeah
i i was i was thinking yeah raw tomatoes
no four
1.6 out of 10. i swear to god out of
5 313 ratings
1.6 and it got renewed
and this is i am they fired all the
entire writing team
and imdb i got to give it to them imdb
is pretty based
they're either really based or they're
really lazy i can't figure out which but
imdb
imdb does nothing to [ __ ] with its
ratings
they just they go look man we have
registered users
they [ __ ] vote on a movie we leave it
the [ __ ] alone if you're a 1.6
i hate to break it to you you're [ __ ]
1.6 that's just how imdp is
1.6 dude
because every morning when i wake up i'm
like why does it feel like i've been
through an extreme sport i don't think i
sleep like a normal person i think i
sleep like this i'm like the worst kama
sutra of sleeping oh yeah a little quad
or these are quadsy quad oh
i'm sweating there's the booty shot for
you why you're gonna be good are you
ready this one's gonna be gonna bring
you near my crotch i have your consent
oh this is the flattery angle right here
this oh yeah um don't take too long it's
just a few minutes look how good my
gallery wall looks oh my god that's
cracks let's crack there now here's the
stretches that really matter because my
neck
problems it's everything with a little
late with lily on rotten tomatoes it's
been a while since we've checked it mike
so ron tomatoes has two different
ratings
um for the show it has the critics
rating and then it has the audience
rating
now i will now i will be the chief this
is rotten tomatoes tomatoes
let's go critic ratings what do you
think is that critical rating
i'm stealing your answer i'm gonna go
with an eight or a seven point five to
an eight eighty-two percent so eight so
you pretty much nailed it what do you
think the audience score is
because now they finally added the
audience remember before they hadn't
added the audio but they also cooked the
audience scores
yes yeah i would agree they probably do
they do they they yeah they hire people
yes so i'm going to go with a 4.5
16 16
wow and that's with a cooked audience
1.6 and then 16 like
this is almost scientifically scary
this one's crucial too a little bit of
these crack crack crack crappy crack
crack crack crack crack
oh so i know when you're in gym class
when you're young they could do the neck
rotations it's actually bad for your
neck to do complete rotations of your
neck the things you learn in adulthood i
swear when i was in grade 2 my teacher
is like all the way around 360.
damaging me for life finish do a simple
pull to one side
this time okay i can't i'm tapping out
i'm done i'm done look she still sucks
folks
all right she still sucks why is she
allowed to exist i don't know man
because
here's what happened you know they
pumped all this money they saw the show
wasn't doing good
so but they can't get rid of her after
one season because they backed
themselves into a whoa corner well it's
what we all said we said that in the
beginning we're like
guys thank you for listening pills pills
pills pills pill spills pills pills
pills pills pills
if you like the music minus that part
soundcloud.com
mythicalvigilante cloud.com mythical
vigilantes
[Music]
somebody we'll be back on monday
pills pills pills pills pills pills